das war in vielerlei hinsicht eine
historische bundestagswahl die wir der
letzten sonntag erlebt haben mit
wirklich einigen erstaunlichen
ergebnissen reden wir darüber mit olaf
schubert er arbeitet für die
forschungsgruppe wahlen und zwar als 400
euro kraft olaf eine mehrheit der
deutschen findet es richtig dass die spd
in die opposition geht was müssten die
genossen machen um mal wieder richtig
erfolg zu haben
ich glaube die müssten mehr leute finden
die die wählen ich sitze der theorie ja
ich kann es nicht beweisen ist natürlich
klar aber ich sage mal in der geschichte
wird man die sozialdemokratische
regierungsverantwortung schon wenn wir
hatten als sowas wie habbo also
vom koalitionspartner wirklich völlig
platt gemacht und ich habe von den
amerikanischen schiffen 100 liegen mir
wenigstens fracks übrig aber von der spd
hat wirklich nur noch nasser lappen also
der ist sogar trocken also aber man muss
es positiv sehen ich meine von allen
klein und spaß parteien ist die spd
immer noch die größe und deshalb ist es
der richtige weg opposition da kannst du
am wenigsten schaden anrichten richtig
57 prozent das fand ich spannend 57
prozent fänden neuerdings jamaica gut
was erhoffst du dir von diesem bündnis
jamaika
ich war dort es ist eine wunderschöne ja
eine eine fruchtbare insel
wenn ich jetzt an unsere kandidaten
denke da die tiere so helgoland aber
warum nicht es ist vielleicht neue klar
ich meine wenn sie alle bemühen wenn
alle parteien wirklich ihr bestes
einbringen also die cdu frau merkel die
fdp ihren pin up boy und die grünen
nicht ja dann würde demokratischen
wähler gedanke durchgesetzt denke schon
bevor wir zu draufkommen lass uns über
sachsen reden in deiner heimat ist die
afg jetzt die stärkste partei geworden
mit 27% hatte ich das überrascht und wie
erklärst du dir dass ich muss sagen ich
habe den wahlabend so ein bisschen
verschlafen also ich werde deine erste
fackel zugedeckt und ich war dann von
ergebnis schon überrascht muss ich sagen
also ich hatte natürlich mit mehr
gerechnet für die ard ich komme ja von
durch also
also aber die konkurrenz war einfach zu
stark hat die npd
klar ich meine für einen richtigen
echten sachsen ist die afg ja nur so ein
verein linksgrünen verhindern und die
npd diesen halt wirklich sauerkraut denn
die asd ehe sag ich mal für einen
moderaten faschismus steht also mit mit
augenmaß und verantwortung und und man
darf die ab die natur jetzt immer nicht
nur reduzieren auf flüchtlinge also die
haben schon auch noch andere themen wie
und und und also ja politik
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mir sehr wichtig ist
[Applaus]
da gibt es auch schnittmengen zum
beispiel mit der abschaffung der gez
also gegen diesen gebühren waren
protestiere ich auch und deshalb trete
ich ja nicht mehr im öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen auf schon seit
jahren muss man auch mal sehen ob wie
viel geld oder verzichten ja aber es
gibt ja ein interessantes phänomen bei
frauen hat die afg nur nur neun prozent
warum ist es in erster linie eine
männerpartei warum sind männer insgesamt
anfälliger für populismus als frauen
weil das ist ein psychisches problem
weil der mann seine männlichkeit nicht
mehr entfalten kann über alles was spaß
macht ist irgendwie verboten ja darf
nicht betrunken auto fahren darf niemand
verprügeln nicht immer innerhalb der
familie weil ich meine unsere großväter
die sind noch durch europa gezogen wie
von bild hans gebissen
die haben sich ausgetobt und wenn wir
heute am ballermann betrunken ein
hitlergruß wird sogleich und hat sich
abgestellt so untermann ist wirklich
fußabtreter gesellschaft und dagegen
wehrt sich der mann im gegensatz zu
frauen von natur aus schon so dass sie
sich unterordnet und fügt zurechtkommt
[Applaus]